هذا موجز الاخبار من قناه الجزيره اهلا
بكم نقلت صحيفه وصله جورنال عن مسؤولين
امريكيين رافعين قولهم ان الغاره
بالمسيرات في ايران قد نفذتها اسرائيل من
جانبه قال البنتاجون انه لم تقم اي قوه
عسكريه امريكيه بشني هجمات او عمليات داخل
ايران واوضح المصدر انه تم استهدافه 4
مواقع مختلفه في المنشاه بدقه مؤكدا ان كل
الضربات حققت اهدافها
قالت مصادر امنيه عراقيه ان اربعه شاحنات
استهدفت بالصواريخ اطلقتها طائرات مسيره
في قريه الهري قرب مدينه البوكمال داخل
الاراضي السوريه من جانبها قاده القناه
الثانيه عشر الاسرائيليه ان القصف استهدف
قافل تابعه ايرانيه كانت في طريقها من
العراق الى سوريا
الايراني
عبر قطر واشهر في مؤتمر صحفي مشترك مع
نظيره القطريه الشيخ محمد بن عبد الرحمن
ال ثاني ان قطر تحاول اعاده جميع الاطراف
في الاتفاق النووي الى التزاماتها
من جهه قال وزير الخارجيه القطريه الشيخ
محمد بن عبد الرحمن ال ثاني خلال لقائه مع
نظيره الايراني ان الدوحه تسعى لتوفير
بيئه ملائمه لعقد جولات تفاوض اضافيه بشان
الاتفاق
قرر رئيس الوزراء الاسرائيلي بنيم نتنياهو
تعزيز الشرطه الاسرائيليه بسرايا من الجيش
لمساعدتها في القدس والمناطق القريبه من
خط كماسا وتوسيع تسليح المستوطنين وقال
نتانياهون الاجراءات الانتقاليه تشمل
مصادره الحق في السكن والاقامه والمواطنه
لعائله منفه
جاء هذا خلال اجتماعي للحكومه بعد ساعات
من اتخاذه الطاقه الوزاريه الاسرائيلي
المصغر سلسله قرارات انتقاميه ضد
الفلسطينيين شملت اغلاق منزلي منفذ عمليه
القدس الشهيد خيري
وصل وزير الخارجيه الامريكي انطوني بلينك
الى القاهره في سياقي جوله تشمل الاراضي
الفلسطينيه واسرائيل بهدف مناقشه التصعيد
في الاراضي الفلسطينيه والتخفيف من حده
التوتر وكذلك لبحث الحفاظ على الوضع
التاريخي في القدس وملف في حل الدولتين
وملفات اخرى
قالت الهيئه العليا المستقله للانتخابات
في تونس ان النسبه العامه الاوليه
للمشاركه في الدور الثاني للانتخابات
التشريعيه تجاوزت 11 في المئه في انتظاره
اعلان نتائج اقرت الهيئه بتدن المشاركه
داعيه لنقاش موضوعيا باشان سبب هذا
قال احمد نجيب الشابي رئيس جبهه الخلص
الوطنيه التونسيه انا نتائج الجوله
الثانيه من الانتخابات التشريعيه اظهرت ان
90% من الشعب التونسيه سحبوا الثقه من
المسار الذي انطلق بانقلاب الخامسه
والعشرين من يوليو
الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]